en todos los ejercicios que voy a hacer
aquí vamos a encontrar el máximo común
divisor ahora la idea básica es que
vamos a tomar el exponente más pequeño
de los factores comunes junto con el
factor común si ya viste el vídeo del
mínimo común múltiplo es básicamente la
misma idea
solo que un poquito diferente en este
ejemplo queremos encontrar el máximo
común divisor de 12 30 y 42 si tus
habilidades matemáticas son muy buenas
seguramente puedes encontrar el máximo
común divisor inmediatamente pero en
este ejercicio vamos a utilizar la forma
larga de obtenerlo porque es la forma
más larga y complicada se puede extender
a otro tipo de ejemplos más complicados
así es que estamos buscando un
procedimiento general queremos
factorizar cada uno de estos números
vamos a empezar por el 12 que se puede
escribir como 4 por 3 luego factor
izamos el 30 que se escribe como 3 por
y el 42 lo podemos escribir como 6 por 7
ahora algunas de estas factorización es
todavía se pueden factorizar más por
ejemplo el 4 lo podemos escribir como 2
por 2 o sea 2 al cuadrado y realmente no
podemos simplificar más al 3 el 3 lo
vamos a dejar igual pero el 10 lo
podemos simplificar como 2 por 5 y bueno
de una vez los estoy acomodando en orden
a los factores y observa que si
multiplicamos a estos 3 obtenemos 30
nuevamente y de la misma forma el 6 se
simplifica en 2 por 3 y aquí tenemos que
multiplicar por 7 y ahora lo que hago
para encontrar el máximo común divisor
es observar la primera factorización y
decir ok aquí tengo un 2 en esta
factoría ción habrá 2 en el resto de las
factorías acciones
y efectivamente si en cada una de las
factorías acciones hay un 2 en la
primera factorización el exponente del 2
es un 2 sin embargo en las otras
factorización es el exponente es 1
entonces tenemos que tomar ese factor 2
pero elevarlo al exponente más chiquito
de las tres factores acciones o sea a la
1 luego nos fijamos en el siguiente
factor que es un 3 y me pongo a pensar
si hay 3 en todas las demás
factorización es bueno hay un 3 en la
segunda factorización y también hay un 3
en la tercera factorización y todos
tienen el mismo exponente 1 entonces en
el máximo común divisor multiplicó por 3
a la 1 y ya terminamos porque es cierto
aquí hay un 5 y un 7 pero en la primera
factorización no hay ni cinco ni siete
si es que ya encontramos el máximo común
divisor es 2 por 3 lo cual es igual a 6
y si lo piensas otra vez el 6 es el
número más grande que divide al 12 al 30
y el 42 pero qué pasa si tenemos números
más grandes
bueno pues tal vez se vuelve un poquito
más complicada la parte aritmética pero
de todas formas podemos con ella así es
que vamos a empezar factor izando a 124
124 es par por lo que podemos poner su
factor 2 por aquí y sabemos que 2 por 62
es igual a 124 212 también es par por lo
que 2 también es uno de sus factores y 2
por 106 es igual a 212 por aquí ponemos
nuestro 2 original y luego 62 lo podemos
escribir como 2
por 31 por aquí ponemos el 2 original y
106 lo podemos escribir como 2 por 53 y
a estas alturas nos podemos detener
porque resulta que el 31 es un número
primo no podemos factorizar más a 31
aunque a 53 pudiéramos factorizar lo
todavía más realmente no importa porque
31 ya no se puede factorizar más si es
que por aquí tenemos 2 al cuadrado por
2 al cuadrado por 53 y otra vez vamos a
hacer exactamente lo mismo para
encontrar nuestro máximo común divisor
por aquí tenemos un factor 2 y en la
otra factorización también tenemos un
factor 2 por lo que tenemos ese factor
común 2 y lo queremos elevar a la mínima
potencia pero los dos tienen una
potencia 2 así es que lo elevamos al
cuadrado y luego pues 31 no se puede
factorizar más 31 no es un factor de 53
así es que ya no tienen más factores en
común por lo que ya sabemos que el
máximo común divisor es igual a 42 al
cuadrado 124 y 212 parece que son
números muy grandes y que debería de
haber algún número más grande que 4 que
los dividiera a los dos sin embargo no
es así bueno vamos a hacer otro
ejercicio sólo que aquí ahora tenemos
variables aunque yo aquí tenemos
elevado a la tercera potencia llegue a
la segunda zeta a la cuarta a eso
también le llamamos x al cubo porque al
cuadrado por zeta a la cuarta esa es la
primera expresión y la segunda expresión
es x a la 4 por seth al cuadrado y la
tercera expresión es de al cubo por
equis a la 5 ahora para encontrar el
máximo común divisor la idea es
exactamente la misma lo primero que hago
es irme a la primera expresión al primer
término que en este caso es x al cubo y
preguntarme si en las demás expresiones
también tienen un factor x y resulta que
si aquí tenemos una equis en la segunda
expresión y también tenemos x en la
tercera expresión en la primera
expresión la equis está elevada al cubo
aquí está elevada a la 4 y aquí está
elevada a las 5 así es que el
exponente es el 3 por lo que me voy a
quedar con x a la 3 en el máximo común
divisor vamos a poner x a la 3 y luego
observamos el segundo factor de la
primera expresión en este caso es que al
cuadrado y nos preguntamos si hay en las
otras dos expresiones sin embargo la
segunda expresión no tiene como factor h
por lo que no podemos poner allí en el
máximo común divisor y luego nos fijamos
en la zeta si hay zeta en la segunda
expresión pero no hay zeta en la tercera
expresión por lo que el máximo común
divisor de estas tres expresiones es x
al cubo
y ahora vamos con otro ejercicio y mira
están mezclados números con variables
pero no importa vamos a empezar por
factorizar los números en la primera
expresión el 8 se puede escribir como 2
por 2 por 2 o sea 2 al cubo y luego
dejamos x al cuadrado como está y al
cubo podemos reescribir al 12 como
cuatro por 304 es 2 al cuadrado por 3
por x al cubo llegué a la quinta y vamos
a hacer lo mismo con 36 que es 9 por 4 0
4 es 2 al cuadrado y 9 estrés al
cuadrado y luego tenemos x elevado a la
potencia 1 y elevado a la 4 por supuesto
puedes tomarte más tiempo a la hora de
simplificar estos números si lo
necesitas pero bueno ahora sí vamos a la
primera expresión el primer término este
2 lo buscamos en las demás
expresiones por aquí están y nos fijamos
en cuál es su mínimo exponente y resulta
que su mínimo exponente es 2 lo cual
significa que mi máximo común divisor
tiene un 2 al cuadrado luego nos fijamos
en el siguiente factor x lo buscamos en
las demás expresiones por aquí están
aquí estamos elevando a la 2 a la 3 y a
la 1 entonces nos quedamos con el 1 que
es el mínimo exponente y en el máximo
común divisor estamos multiplicando por
equis a la 1 y nuevamente nos fijamos en
el siguiente factor ya vemos si está en
todas las demás expresiones nos fijamos
en sus exponentes tenemos un 3 un 5 y un
4 y nos quedamos con el exponente más
pequeño nos quedamos con ya a la 3
si es que el máximo común divisor de
estas tres expresiones es cuatro por
equis porque al cubo vamos con el
siguiente ejercicio
ahora tenemos cosas entre paréntesis
pero sigue siendo la misma idea tenemos
x + 2 al cubo por x a la 4 x 2 x menos 1
elevado a las 7 y luego la siguiente
expresión es x + 2 elevado a las 5 x 2 x
menos 1 elevado a la 4 y vamos a seguir
exactamente las mismas instrucciones nos
vamos al primer factor de la primera
expresión en este caso es x + 2 y nos
fijamos si la otra expresión también
tiene el factor x + 2
comparamos los exponentes y nos quedamos
con el más chico las 10 que el máximo
común divisor tiene como factor a x + 2
a la 3
y luego nos vamos al siguiente término
que en este caso es x a la 4 lo
busquemos en la otra expresión pero pues
la otra expresión no tiene ninguna equis
elevada a ninguna potencia lo cual
significa que el máximo común divisor no
tiene ninguna equis como factor nos
vamos al siguiente término que es 2x
menos uno nos fijamos si la otra
expresión también tiene 2x menos 1 y
aquí está por aquí la potencia de 7 y
por acá la potencia es 4 nos quedamos
con la más chica así es que el máximo
común divisor tiene como factor 2 x
menos uno elevado a la 4 y listo ese es
el máximo común divisor de esas dos
expresiones
hagamos otro ejercicio por aquí tenemos
la expresión x al cuadrado menos 4 y la
otra expresión x al cuadrado más 5 x + 6
la diferencia entre este ejercicio y los
anteriores es que en los otros
ejercicios ya teníamos todas las
expresiones factor izadas y aquí no aquí
nosotros tenemos que empezar factor
izando las ahora x al cuadrado menos 4
sabemos que es x + 2 x x menos 2
x al cuadrado 5 x 6 se puede factorizar
como x 2 x x + 3 y entonces este
ejercicio es muy parecido al ejercicio
anterior
tenemos x + 2 en las dos expresiones así
es que el máximo común divisor tiene
como factor x + 2 y luego aquí tenemos
un x menos 2 pero en la segunda
expresión no tenemos x menos 2 entonces
este es nuestro máximo común divisor
este simple x + 2 bueno espero que te
hayan servido estos ejemplos